so knowing that you feel that maybe
you should not have
stuck with something because you feel
that maybe you passed on certain
opportunities or it caused certain
things to happen
um
what would be your litmus test
the next time around with something in
terms of keeping your promise
borrowing being paid and all that and
it's tough it's tough because
you know
the way it's just funny it's like um
in a sense i was my own completion bond
company or whatever like i self
guaranteed that we'd finish
which you know looking back was just a
silly that's just silly man like it's
one thing to work on a project and to be
paid to work on it or to have a passion
project and try your best it's a whole
other category when you make a promise
the way i did and i just
it was rough it was really really rough
and and like looking back like i don't
think i do that again i don't think that
i would make a personal
promise on something the way i did
because
it just puts you in this weird like yes
you're passionate about finishing your
project but wait you have to finish it
it
puts a twist on it and and there were
times where i found where it's just like
i don't like this
i don't enjoy you know sitting for 15
hours a day
and editing
although i love editing you know it's
like i'm passionate about filmmaking and
i love editing and i love
but there were just days that it was
just like
i'm only doing this because i have to
and it was just like i found any
distraction i possibly could and that
was way more interesting sitting around
drinking water going for a walk
checking email is there anything
you know ultimately i had to disconnect
the internet i had you know the battery
on my phone internet
i couldn't
i couldn't have any distractions there
there were there were months and months
at a time i remember sitting from like
november 2011 all the way through
february three months no internet no
distractions 15 hours a day editing
trying to get the assembly edit finished
in the film
it was tough it was really tough
but i think that's really commendable
because so many people
they want all these things but it there
are parts where it's just incredibly
frustrating and a lot of us don't have
that willpower myself included sometimes
to finish stuff willpower is exactly the
word that i put on it i say i say that i
will powered through you know
and and that's what you do and it's like
how do you
get that will power well for me
i didn't have a choice i i felt like i
didn't have a choice i mean ultimately i
could have walked away i could have said
well i can't finish this i promise i'd
finish it and i can't
but but i feel i feel like a betrayal i
feel like a betrayal i would have
betrayed
the people that had trusted me
to finish it and and
you know ultimately i just kept at it
but don't you think that's a mark of a
professional
to to power through no matter what i
mean now don't you think that somebody
else could come along and look at what
you've done and say okay hey he finished
that that sounds incredibly difficult to
have 25 plus people working
collaborating on a project i don't think
i could do that all right well
if anyone's calling you know here's my
calling card uh i did it
it's done
here's this crazy documentary um
and and
i
i feel like i'm just a drop in a bucket
you know there's just so many people out
there and so many projects and
and
you know it comes back to like wow how
does anyone know
that the project's finished it comes
back to you know what i'm in right now
which is releasing the film you know
getting the word out how do you
how do you make sure that people even
know that the project's there so